madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal après le suicide d'un
instituteur en avril dernier
soupçonné de pédophilie des photos
pornographiques ont été découvertes dans
son ordinateur
mais ces nouveaux frais continuent
malgré tout de diviser les familles
certaines convaincu de l'innocence de
l'enseignant le dernier pont avant les
vacances d'été une journée classée
orange par bison futé pour ces départs
sur les routes d'un week end de
pentecôte sous surveillance les forces
de police traque les récidivistes de la
vitesse
les difficultés financières de lohan qui
est rétrogradé en deuxième division
bernard tapie a tenu une conférence de
presse de lundi il fera appel de cette
décision qui provoque une véritable
émotion sur la canebière dans les gorges
du verdon ouverture du musée de la
préhistoire dans ce site spectaculaire à
bâtiment d'avant garde à la recherche de
notre très lointain passé
je vous le disais en titre de nouveaux
éléments à charge semblerait confirmer
les soupçons de pédophilie contre
l'instituteur desitter shy'm qui s'est
suicidé en avril dernier à l'époque de
nombreux habitants du village avaient
rejeté ces accusations et aujourd'hui
encore malgré la présence de photos
pornographiques retrouver dans la
mémoire de l'ordinateur de l'enseignant
les parents d'élèves restent sceptiques
voire diviser certains ont même évoqué
l' acharnement de la justice sur place
georges solar et patricia cher la
justice a donc été rapide
un mois et demi à peine jusqu'à ce
rendez vous devant le juge pour les
parents d'élèves 49 jours d' enquête
pour expliquer d'abord le suicide de
paul jacques un instituteur de
zittersheim au moment même où les
gendarmes l'interpeller pour agression
sexuelle sur mineur depuis une centaine
d'élèves a donc été auditionné
l'ordinateur de l'école expertise est
aujourd'hui le juge d'instruction est
formel il y a bien eu perversion les
preuves sont là on n'avait pas pensé
qu'il puisse y avoir quelque chose sur
les fichiers informatiques de l'école
n'a vu que des fautes photos porno avec
des enfants et des choses très dures à
voir sur lesquels on a
par aucune nous enfants mais qu'ils
étaient des photos qui ont dû être
prises sur des sites internet plus de
200 photos datées à caractère pédophile
retrouvées sur l'ordinateur de
l'instituteur quant aux auditions des
anciens élèves elles ont permis de
retrouver d'autres victimes
d'autres témoins l'ensemble des enfants
qui ont présents qui ont fréquenté
l'école ont été entendus et à l'heure
actuelle on peut dire qu'il y a au moins
quatre enfants victimes les faits sont
graves établi par la justice et pourtant
d'autre part en défenseur acharné de
l'instituteur refuse encore l'évidence
il ya eu plein de rater de dérapage et
puis bon maintenant naturellement il
leur faut un coupable ça c'est mon
impression après les enfants victimes
c'est donc la justice que ces adultes
refusent de croire
quels que soient les faits qu'on
pourrait amener je crois
les gens sont sombres malgré le
témoignage des enfants malgré le travail
de la justice
le petit village de zittersheim est
encore en plein drame / les querelles et
rancoeurs un seul homme paul jacquin
aurait pu éclaircir la situation
mais le 12 avril dernier il a préféré le
suicide et la mort aux questions des
gendarmes
on commence à en savoir davantage sur
cette affaire de viol qui s'est produite
en plein après-midi de l'ascension dans
un train sans susciter apparemment de
réaction de la part des voyageurs la
victime une étudiante à lille a porté
plainte dès le lendemain aujourd'hui son
avocat s'exprime alors qu'aucun témoin
ne s'est manifesté hier je vous le
rappelle quatre jeunes adolescents ont
été mises en examen pour viol collectif
à bord du train un seul contrôleur sur
une ligne très fréquentée reliant
dunkerque ali se fit rodier frédéric
ballan depuis ce matin le dunkerque
lille et sous haute surveillance dans la
rame les agents de la brigade
ferroviaire sont pris à partie par les
passagers choqués cette jeune fille
laisse éclater sa colère mais ça fait
deux ans que je prends le train je suis
étudiante comme cette jeune femme sur
l'île et je vous ai jamais vu je suis
désolé jeudi de l'ascension and 21 noms
regagne lille après avoir passé la
journée en famille
18h15 en garde bailleul cinq jeunes tous
mineurs monte dans le wagon le train est
bondé 200 personnes à bord selon la sncf
très vite les adolescents s'en prennent
violemment à la jeune fille dans ce
train et bien elle a été abordée par une
bande de jeunes qui lui ont fait subir
un certain doute rage qui sont qualifiés
de viol c'est-à-dire des actes de
pénétrations sexuelles et elle se
trouvait à peu isolés entre parenthèses
c'est à dire que il semblerait que
d'autres participants d'autres voyageurs
et vianney pas réagit absolument
absolument le cauchemar dure 30 minutes
30 minutes pendant lesquelles personne
ne bouge le signal d'alarmé n'est même
pas tirer aucun signalement non plus
auprès du contrôleur un silence dénoncé
par la sncf l'indifférence en fait les
cas la somme de nos indifférences
individuel donc chacun nous l'avons fait
nous prenons notre part pour que le 6 le
civisme effectivement soit totalement
totalement partagé les quatre agresseurs
issus d'un quartier sensible de l'île
ont tous des antécédents judiciaires
en fin d'après-midi un cinquième suspect
identifié grâce à un portrait robot
était entendu par les services de police
près forte mobilisation des gendarmes
sur les routes de france pour ce départ
en week-end de pentecôte bison futé a
prévu une journée orange aujourd'hui ne
s'est pas trompé dans ce dernier pont
avant les vacances d'été réputé pour
être l'un des plus meurtriers de l'année
la sécurité routière a décidé de
s'attaquer aux récidivistes de la
vitesse avec un dispositif plutôt
musclée dans la région rhône-alpes et
vincent fourcade et olivier jacquelin
comme à chaque grand départ en week end
la totalité des forces de sécurité
routière de la région est au bord des
routes
nous sommes sur la nationale 7 celle des
vacances en pleine zone urbaine
croisement et passage de riverains sont
nombreux le trafic ininterrompue en
moins de vingt minutes
cinq personnes ont allègrement dépassé
la limite des 50 km heure avant d'être
contrainte à un arrêt forcé c'est bien
ça permet de lever le pied cette saison
les gendarmes ont une priorité la chasse
aux habitués des excès de vitesse
une méthode simple sur un même axe
plusieurs radars guette le contrevenant
est le fait de qu'ils soient contrôlés
comme ça en plusieurs points déployer
tous les 7 km
est de nature à faire un rappel à la loi
pour éviter la récidive
trois jours durant le trafic est
multiplié par trois et trois cent mille
véhicules déferle sur les routes du
soleil un nombre en constante
augmentation dans le centre nerveux de
la circulation rhônalpine les
contrôleurs voit ainsi chaque année de
plus en plus de français profiter de ces
week end à rallonge
c'est un phénomène qu'on constate déjà
depuis quelques années notamment avec un
peu la réduction qui étaient
actuellement en cours sur les temps de
travail donc la possibilité aux gens
devaient d'avoir les vendredis pour
l'heure pour profiler g lent départ et
allonger leur départ de week end si
aujourd'hui le trafic est classée orange
il deviendra rouge dimanche c'est la
journée la plus dangereuse 34 décès l'an
dernier après la mise en examen de volvo
france 2 autre accident impliquant une
voiture du constructeur automobile
suédois seraient survenus dans des
circonstances identiques mettant en
cause le système de freinage du véhicule
en cette époque où les constructeurs
privilégié à tout prix le principe de
précaution on s'interroge sur l'attitude
de volvo qui n'a pas rappelé l'ensemble
des voitures concernées
elisabeth benêt et patrick voir le pdg
de volvo s'attendait à sa mise en examen
pour homicides et blessures
involontaires
il compte d'ailleurs convoqué ses
propres experts pour faire la lumière
sur l'accident survenu il ya deux ans
dans le village alsacien de wasselonne
la conductrice de cette volvo 850 tdi
perd le contrôle de son véhicule
deux enfants sont tués la première
expertise conclut à une vitesse
excessive
mais la deuxième en mars dernier mettons
cause la défaillance du système de
freinage
une défaillance connu de volvo mais pour
la direction
elle n'a aucun rapport avec l'accident
il n'y avait pas de questions de
sécurité il n'y avait pas de question de
problèmes de freinage ni persistant de
freinage pas de rappel des véhicules
volvo se contente d'une note technique à
ses concessionnaires
le constructeur leur demande de
contacter les clients et de remplacer la
pièce défectueuse
une pratique courante et discrète pour
réparer des failles techniques d'une en
général les rappels silencieux soit ils
ne touchent que des problèmes qui ne
concerne pas la sécurité sont les faits
au début de lancement d'un modèle parce
qu'on sait qu'il n'ya pas beaucoup de
modèles en circulation
mais lorsque la sécurité est en jeu le
constructeur rappelle systématiquement
les véhicules
ce fut le cas des renault twingo ou des
peugeot 206 revenu aux ateliers pour des
problèmes d'airbag volvo at-il
sous-estimé le risque encouru par ses
clients
la justice tranchera à créteil cet après
midi une marche silencieuse en hommage
aux motards de la police qui a été
renversé par une voiture dans la nuit de
mercredi 3 roma qui avait pris la fuite
ont été placés en garde à vue
aujourd'hui
les obsèques de cet homme de 45 ans qui
a donc trouvé la mort dans cet accident
se dérouleront demain on évoque ce soir
la piste du gang des horodateurs la
manifestation des surveillante de prison
ils ont tapé en fin d'après-midi un
large mouvement jeudi prochain qui
pourrait paralyser les établissements
pénitentiaires c'est du moins le
souhaitent des principaux représentants
syndicaux qui conduisait aujourd'hui une
manifestation a friend à poissy et à la
santé après je vous rappelle la
tentative d'évasion par hélicoptère
dimanche dernier l'occasion d'écouter le
témoignage de ces femmes de surveillants
qui disent leur inquiétude et leur
colère
c'est anne breitner et daniil des filles
anaïs quatre mois ne sait pas encore
quel métier fait papa sa mère l angoisse
tous les jours
cette secrétaire a épousé un surveillant
de prison et depuis que le surveillant
nico est entre la vie et la mort après
la prise d'otages de fresnes
elle se pose encore plus de questions je
me suis honnêtement à la place de les
pousses du surveillant je me suis dit
mais c'est dramatique
elle est elle même maman de deux jeunes
enfants tout comme moi donc je me dise
ça peut arriver à n'importe qui c'est
c'est dramatique et pour les enfants et
pour les pouces
depuis la tentative d'évasion de
dimanche dernier la colère des
surveillants monte chaque jour un peu
plus aujourd'hui une vingtaine de prison
étaient touchées par le mouvement
les gardiens dénoncent des conditions de
travail de plus en plus dangereuse
eux qui n'ont pour seule arme qu un
sifflet on se fait agresser
systématiquement on se fait insulter
bon maintenant se fait tirer dessus bon
c'est pas d'aujourd'hui qu'on se fait
tirer dessus mais aujourd'hui c'est sans
douleur c'était semblant dimanche il y
en a ras-le-bol
pour unifier ce mouvement les syndicats
se sont réunis cet après midi l'ufap
majoritaire fo et la cgt lance une grève
nationale jeudi prochain dans les 187
établissements du pays
il y aura ni entrée ni sortie de détenus
si on continue à laisser laxisme
s'installer dans les prisons françaises
comme le fait actuellement le
gouvernement
bien évidemment on ira au pirée jusqu'à
moore dorment ce soir les manifestations
continuent en particulier à fleury
mérogis les surveillants tenteront
d'empêcher les nombreux mouvements de
détenus habituel au milieu de la nuit
dans la plus grande prison d'europe la
suite du voyage de lionel jospin en
afrique du sud de l'occasion pour le
premier ministre d'assurer du soutien de
la france qui devrait devenir un
partenaire privilégié de ce pays
nouvelle rencontre à johannesburg entre
nelson mandela il le chef du
gouvernement français sur place gitans
berg et jean-paul chaussée
dans la ville d'un politique il ya sans
doute des accolades plus impressionnante
que d'autres lionel jospin y pensait
peut-être ce matin en franchissant le
seuil de la maison de nelson mandela
accueilli par un géant de 82 ans qui
demeure même éloigné du pouvoir
le personnage le plus respecté du pays
le plus écouté
l'homme qui continue d'incarner
l'afrique du sud ce que d'une certaine
manière lionel jospin lui a dit j'ai
apprécié la vision que vous avez donné
quelques minutes
ce n'est pas la seule fois loin de là
que le premier ministre se sera exprimé
en anglais pendant ces deux jours hier à
plusieurs reprises devant le parlement
aujourd'hui encore devant un parterre de
chefs d'entreprise
mais c'est une autre afrique du sud que
celle des milieux d'affaires qui fait au
programme cet après midi le turn type de
ma mélodie une cité pauvre comme
l'afrique du sud en comptant un de ses
ancien bidonville que la fin de
l'apartheid n'a pas aboli ici ne vivent
que des noirs à ma mélodie lionel jospin
est venu visiter un dispensaire en
hôpital de jour le plus au numéro un
c'est le sida la maladie touche plus de
10% de la population du pays et en
afrique du sud aujourd'hui tout le monde
ne parle que de la mort de ngozi johnson
ce jeune garçon qui avait ému dans le
monde entier en s'exprimant à la tribune
d'une conférence internationale prendre
que sa courte vie s'est terminée en même
temps un choc et en même temps il a
témoigné à travers cette courte vie pour
les millions d'hommes et de femmes en
afrique qui sont menacés une dernière
note souriante ce soir lionel jospin
salue les footballeurs locaux champions
d'afrique du sud
mais c'est d'abord sous le signe grave
de la solidarité dans la lutte contre le
sida que lionel jospin a voulu inscrire
sa visite de deux jours en afrique du
sud
dans ce pays le plus touché au monde par
le sida nous venons de vous le dire l'un
des jeunes porte drapeau de cette
épidémie un enfant de 12 ans devenu
symbole de la lutte contre cette maladie
s'est donc éteint ce matin après des
mois d'agonie
il avait mis ses dernières forces pour
plaider en faveur des malades du sida
nelson mandela lui a rendu un vibrant
hommage en qualifiant l'enfant d'icône
de la lutte pour la vie en continu toute
sa vie nkosi s'est battu contre le sida
toute sa courte vie qui s'est achevée la
nuit dernière à 12 ans aux côtés de sa
mère adoptive gail johnson il était
devenu à 8 ans l'enfant emblème de la
lutte contre la maladie en afrique du
sud
d'abord en obtenant une inscription dans
une école chic qui ne voulait pas de lui
parce qu'il était malade
puis l'an dernier en prononçant un
discours lors de l'ouverture d'une
conférence sur le sida
il a exhorté le président de son pays à
autoriser la distribution d'un vtt aux
femmes enceintes
mais la maladie avec laquelle le petit
garçon était né a finalement eu raison
de lui
hier dans son sommeil il a mené son
combat est un combat que peu d'adultes
je suis fier très fier de lui
mais oui il est partant nelson mandela
lui-même avec érigé nicosie en exemple
dans ce pays qui compte le plus de
séropositifs au monde
il veut a rendu hommage il était
exemplaire dans sa manière de montrer
comment on doit faire face à une telle
épreuve
il a été très courageux et il a touché
beaucoup de cas on estime que cette
année encore 70 enfants naîtront comme
cosy porteurs de la maladie en afrique
du sud
en israël des dizaines de milliers de
palestiniens ont pris possession de
jérusalem-est le temps d'un après midi
un immense cortège venu assister aux
obsèques de ce haut dignitaire
palestiniens faysal husseini emporté par
une crise cardiaque la veille image
symbolique de cet immense défilé à
travers le quartier musulman sans aucun
militaire israélien en vue reportage
agnès vahramian et joseph handal demain
aux mains littéralement porté par la
foule
le cercueil traverse l'esplanade des
mosquées et salue ceni était un
personnage charismatique et mais pour sa
droiture son engagement lors des
négociations de paix pour la cause
palestinienne
il n'était jamais fatigué il a fait face
à toutes les difficultés toutes les
humiliations de l'occupation israélienne
il voulait la fin de cette occupation
pour que son peuple vivre libre dans la
dignité
quelques heures plus tôt c'est yasser
arafat qui accueillait haram halal
dépouille de celui qui fut son compagnon
mais le leader palestinien n'a pas suivi
le cortège jusqu'à jérusalem
il ne vient pas dans la ville qu'ils
considèrent occuper la foule
palestinienne elle n'aurait pas dû
passer depuis ramallah
les territoires sont bouclées depuis
huit mois mais débordés les soldats
israëliens renonce c'est la première
depuis la nouvelle intifada
les soldats ont désarmé ils ont peur et
baylet ce qu'ils croient que jérusalem
et aux israéliens mais c'est notre
kabylité aux barrages tentative de
contrôle d'un véhicule ont frôlé
l'émeute
deux cent mille palestiniens comberge
alors vers jérusalem est avec le
sentiment que la ville est un instant
libéré
après ça cll ousseni dans sa mort a
réalisé ce qu'il a voulu tout au long de
sa vie ouvrir jérusalem aux palestiniens
rompre le siège quelques pierres après
les funérailles quelques incidents mais
les soldats se sont faits discrets
l'armée israélienne a réellement disparu
quelques heures de la vieille ville de
jérusalem est et cela pour éviter les
affaires car ces funérailles ont tourné
à la manifestation nationale
palestinienne aux états unis dans l'état
d'idaho depuis plusieurs jours six
enfants armés âgés de 8 à 16 ans se sont
barricadés dans leurs maisons leurs
mères ayant été arrêté par les services
sociaux
considérant qu'elle n'était pas apte à
élever ses enfants cette arrestation
intervenant quelques jours après le
décès du père cette affaire suscite une
certaine émotion en amérique
les adolescents sont assiégées par les
forces de l'ordre
ils n'ont pas hésité à lâcher leur chien
sur la police doit qui a été de ce
vendredi on retiendra la rétrogadation
de l'olympique de marseille en deuxième
division à chocs pour le club et pour la
ville l'om n'a plus les moyens
financiers de ses ambitions
bernard tapie a donné une conférence de
presse en fin d'après midi le club
devrait faire appel dès lundi prochain
julien beaumont le compte est bon voilà
le titre de la future pièce de bernard
tapie actuelle la direction nationale de
contrôle et de gestion rétrograde l'om
en d2 motifs déficit marseillais trop
importants at 2 bernard tapie réplique
l'om est une entreprise saine
mais en deuxième division avec la
situation financière et croyez-moi
vachement bonne les résultats
d'exploitation sont nuls
mais la situation financière du club
avec dreyfus comme actionnaire principal
je vous assure qu'il ya très peu
personnes en france et pas franchement
ce qu'ils connaissent ce conte sur la
cua les salaires sont payés les factures
chante tout payer enfin je sais pas quoi
vous dire tout et pays pourtant
aujourd'hui pour 1 franc gagné l'om en
dépensent deux le déficit atteint les
265 millions de francs pour le réduire
l'om s'est bien séparé de gallas chelsea
l'achète 65 millions 265 moins 65
il manque encore 200 millions de francs
alors adieu voitures de luxe et joueurs
bien payé l'effectif des 39 footballeurs
devraient être intégrés c'est dans la
précipitation et donc en partie à perte
des économies sans doute insuffisant
acte 3 robert louis dreyfus met à
nouveau la main à la poche
il a déjà versé 850 millions de francs
cher payé pour finir 15e du championnat
pour l'om tout va maintenant se jouer
devant la commission d'appel
bonne nouvelle l'avocat qui a rétrogradé
l'équipe se veut rassurant tous les
clubs qui sont sanctionnés par notre
commission et qui font appels peuvent
présenter un dossier qui est
complètement différent de celui qu'ils
ont présentée en première instance
donc si les dirigeants de ces clubs
décident de répondre aux attentes de la
commission je ne vois pas pourquoi on
appelle la décision ne serait pas
affirmé l'om a quinze jours pour monter
son dossier
quinze jours pour boucler son budget
titre de la prochaine pièce la chasse
aux millions
et sur la canebière jusqu'aux portes de
la mairie ans commente l événement le
maire de marseille lui même jugeant
inadmissible cette menace pour le club
michael darmon christophe larocque a pas
d'affolement bien sûr d'une terrasse à
l'autre on en parle mais devant cette
fameuse menace de l'om en deuxième
division à marseille on reste des tâches
et propre qui vont descendre en d2 à
dreyfus et pour quel âge du souhait
ça va s'arranger j'suis pas su parfaire
ma seule supporters de lille j'arrive de
lille voilà les c'est dommage
ambiance nettement plus tendue chez les
supporters organise et supporte le calme
est championne d'europe au club des
yankees on ne plaisante pas avec l'amour
de l'om ni avec les finances les
quelques abonnés qui vole déjà être
remboursés sont rayés des listes à
jamais ici la colère est surtout dirigée
contre le président robert louis dreyfus
je pense plutôt que c'est une partie de
poker entre louis dreyfus qui décidément
et m me marier leduby tonnes depuis
trois jours nous annonce que ça va être
difficile parce qu'il n'a pas les bonnes
documind parce que il ne m'a pas
forcément la capacité de convaincre la
dncg
je crois que quand on est directeur
financier d'une institution comme l'om
et komba passer un examen de passage
devant la dncg 1 arrive gonflé à bloc et
on annonce partout comme la gagne de son
côté le maire de marseille monte au
créneau pour le président de l'om
monsieur dreyfus a déjà mis plus de 900
millions dans l'olympique de marseille
je suis sûr qu'il fera encore les
efforts nécessaires bah écoute et ce
quand même un peu ahuri chante comme but
se traitait l'om de cette manière
une habitude entre l'om l'enfant
turbulent du foot et les instances
parisiennes
les tempêtes sont fréquentes et celle là
devrait durer au moins 10 jours
quant à toulouse déjà relégué en
deuxième division le club est rétrogradé
en national n'ayant pas de garanties
financières suffisantes son président
fera appel dans le département de
l'aisne de plusieurs centaines de fûts
toxiques serait dans fui dans une cour
du sinn dégageant une odeur de produits
chimiques
le pdg de l'entreprise de tissus a été
placé en garde à vue hier c'est une
association pour la défense de
l'environnement qui avaient porté
plainte une enquête a été ouverte sur
cette heure en fout issement suspect de
résidus de produits polluants une
certaine opacité entoure est jusqu'à
présent l'installation des cultures ogm
en france qui je vous le rappelle sont
interdites en partie à l'exception de
trois variétés de maïs aujourd'hui le
ministère de l'agriculture publie lui
même la carte des sites
d'expérimentation mais cette décision de
lever le voile sur ses pratiques n'a pas
rassuré pour autant
les communes concernées l'exemple dans
le lot-et-garonne à monheurt séverine
lebrun et nicolas le marié jacq et
agriculteurs bio régulièrement ces
légumes sont contrôlés il doit respecter
à la lettre toutes les règles de la
production biologique mais il est de
plus en plus inquiet car il sait que sur
sa commune il existe un site
d'expérimentation de cultures ogm
sa crainte que du pollen navigue d'un
champ ogm sur ses propres terres il faut
s'éloigner le plus possible
le plus possible des gens mais le
problème pour nous c'est de savoir si de
l'autre côté de la route c'est un maïs
ogm ou pas vous voyez il ya bien
quelques soupçons sur des parcelles
avoisinantes mais impossible de vérifier
qu'on aimerait c'est que tout hormis
tous agriculteurs qui fait soit des
cultures soient des essais soient
obligés de signaler
c'est aujourd'hui dont la plus grande
discrétion que le ministère de
l'agriculture a publié sur son site la
fameuse carte
elle répertorie toutes les
expérimentations ogm en france
une quarantaine de départements sont
concernés essentiellement dans le nord
et le sud ouest
il ne s'agit pas de cultures destinées à
l'alimentation
mais bien de tests sur le maïs le colza
ou les betteraves de grandes firmes
privées comme monsanto novartis des
laboratoires publics étudient les ogm
leur productivité leur impact sur
l'environnement ou la santé
jusqu'à présent le ministère refusé de
dévoiler ces informations pour éviter ça
ici un collectif anti ogm menée par josé
bové saccage des plants de riz
transgénique 18 mois de recherche partis
en fumée actuellement on france seuls
trois variétés de maïs transgéniques
sont autorisés à la culture
et cela concerne seulement une centaine
d'hectares
les agriculteurs restent prudents
alahmad la lance sa campagne pour les
présidentielles il a choisi la ville de
nîmes avant la feria pour se lancer dans
l'arène politique de l'élection de 2002
l'occasion pour le président de
démocratie libérale de mobiliser les
élus locaux de son parti laurence
ostolaza chine a pris hier alain madelin
déjà dans la bataille
en revanche point des thèmes de campagne
sécurité et emploi
il fait l'apologie des petits métiers
point de départ de ce qu'il appelle
l'ascenseur social qu'il ya des
possibilités de plein de petits boulots
feria de nîmes symbole d'une entrée dans
l'arène présidentielle le candidat se
frotte à tous les électorats une image
de candidat ce travail
outre la fête l'objectif de cette
tournée en languedoc-roussillon c'est
l'inauguration des comités de soutien
dont la mission est de prêcher la parole
de la modernité c'est quoi au juste
les vocations
ni moderne centre a place for l'enfant
contrat
dans ses propos il est jeune et
dynamique il a une image jeune martelé
comment la belle quatre thèmes forts de
campagne 4 révolution libérale de la
fiscalité de l'état de l'école mais
aussi de la région et c'est en fer
languedocienne que le président de
démocratie libérale a prôné
l'émancipation législatives de toutes
les régions françaises et pas seulement
de la corse pour enfants le rôle des
régions dans la constitutio de permettre
à ces évolutions fiscales cette année
fiscale et cette évolution booba
réglementaires dans une grande loi
d'orientation dans une réforme
constitutionnelle et s'il le faut nous
la soumettre au débat les français et la
nouvelle au référendum au rock de tous
les français
objectif 2002 pour alain madelin
convaincre un électorat de droite qui
risque dans les prochains moins d'avoir
l'embarras du choix
l'extrême gauche pourrait bien
constituer une embarrassante épine dans
le clip du gouvernement jospin après des
années des années de luttes voilà
qu'arlette laguiller alain krivine
forts de leur résultat aux européennes
aux dernières municipales risque de
peser sur les prochaines élections à
partir de demain et pendant trois jours
lutte ouvrière se met à la fête
reportage thierry clopeau philip kerr
professeur de lettres à doué rejet marie
à 25 ans de militantisme et lutte
ouvrière marxiste léniniste ila est élu
pour la première fois en mars conseiller
municipal dans la banlieue dortoir de
sin-le-noble ans maintenant deuxième
tour il a fait perdre parti communiste
un de ses bastions du nord-pas-de-calais
au profit de l'udf aujourd'hui l'extrême
gauche inquiète la gauche plurielle et
grâce à son militantisme dans
l'entreprise vampirise l'électorat du
pc7 gauche payer la politique parlant ça
va ils ont fait peu de co2
en militant justement et des aspirations
de la classe ouvrière il a fallu quand
même qu'ils oublient bien tout ça pour
aller soutenir le parti socialiste et
mener la même politique que lui alors il
le paye comme l'an dernier roger mari
sera ce week-end aux côtés d'arlette
laguillier et des trente mille militants
de la fête de lutte ouvrière dans le val
d'oise
revigoré par le bon score des
municipales et le discours radical sur
les licenciements boursiers
arlette superstar fait tout l'été les
seuls printemps de l'extrême gauche pour
faire céder sur l'interdiction des
licenciements pour un nouveau mai 68 et
une nouvelle grève générale
un nouveau jeu va trop loin parce que
finalement c'est un peu la même
la même chose à te dire que il ya un
mouvement d'ensemble
d'ailleurs les deux leaders de l'extrême
gauche arlette laguiller alain krivine
n'appelle pas à voter tout du moins
aujourd'hui lionel jose par second tour
des présidentielles il vise ne pas faire
le jeu de la droite c'était la gauche
gouvernementale de se responsabiliser
les voir des quartiers populaires les
voix des jeunes etc faut aller les
chercher vous même on sera pas votre
chère pas à ce jour
arlette l'aiguillé la seule candidate
révolutionnaire déclaré à la
présidentielle ce n'est pas encore le
grand soir mais avec 7% des intentions
de vote
elle se place devant robert hue son
électorat populaire sera plus que jamais
courtisé par la gauche plurielle et
voilà que l'on reparle de l'éventuelle
empoisonnement de naples et en une
nouvelle expertise menée par deux
médecins français relance le débat sur
les circonstances de la mort de
l'empereur
il y aurait bien présence d'arsenic sur
des cheveux supposées appartenir à
napoléon mais il faut rester extrêmement
prudent ces nouvelles recherches
n'indique pas l'empoisonnement à
l'arsenic
même s'il conforte les fanatiques de
cette thèse l'assassinât du prisonnier
de sainte-hélène de nick marche
le mystère plane toujours sur les
invalides et leurs précieux trésor le
corps de napoléon bonaparte à
l'instigation de l'homme d'affaires
canadien bender plusieurs scientifiques
français ont en effet confirmé la thèse
selon laquelle napoléon malades avaient
reçu des doses d'arsenic anormalement
importante mais non mortels il était
clair que l'altération des taj mahal
l'affaiblissement considérable de la
santé napoléon par la maladie lui serve
éventuellement vers culoz on sait qu'il
était une vertu le plus
l'affaiblissement chronique de son
organisme par des taux d'arsenic
accumulées pendant des années donc cet
affaiblissement avait engendré une
fragilité par rapport à un événement
donc l'enquêté rebondit donc après les
premières analyses
vieil américain en 1995 contesté par les
historiens français persuadés de
l'assassinât du plus célèbre des
français l'homme d'affaires canadien
s'acharne comme certains restoria depuis
40 ans et enseigne que la peau lion est
mort d'un cancer
si difficile de changer leurs idées
après tant d'années de prêcher un cancer
de l'estomac alors ils sont assez
intelligents mais il peut pas de
l'avouer pas ce que c'est embarrassant
et le rideau seront infectées je sais
par le réputation
de nouvelles preuves donc mais pas
encore d'explication l' enquête sur la
mort de napoléon bonaparte a certes
progressé sans encore répondre à toutes
les questions
il s'agit du fémur d'un gigantesque
dinosaure vieux de 94 millions d'années
ring cela il a été découvert en egypte
par une équipe de paléontologues
américains cet animal préhistorique
l'once de 31 mètres devait peser
quelques 76 tonnes il serait alors le
deuxième plus grand dinosaure connu dans
les gorges du verdon l'ouverture dans ce
site spectaculaire du nouveau musée de
la préhistoire premier visite guidée
dans ce lieu d'avant garde à la
découverte de notre patrimoine le plus
reculé
celui des cavernes occupé depuis la nuit
des temps jarre dalmaz d'inscrits
mystère des ténèbres vert bleu du verdon
dans les falaises du canyon provençal
des grottes pershing plusieurs dizaines
depuis la nuit des temps
elles ont entassé les traces de nos
ancêtres des cavernes exemple
labeaume bonne non loin de quinson le
grand explorateur dès 1957 en a été
henri de l'hommelet lot de nos
préhistorien content au niveau mondial
ce qui étonne c'est la capacité des
hommes de néanderthal de trouver les
bons coins il y a cinq cent mille ans
l'homme fait partie de la nature est un
élément de la nature et à l'époque avant
les peuples premiers peuples face aux
lecteurs l'homme vit en équilibre avec
la nature
il connaît parfaitement son
environnement et il allait trouver la
grotte idéal bien exposé bien protégés
et qui est qui lui donnait accès à
toutes sortes de niche écologique
c'est-à-dire autant de gardes branché
qui est qu à sa disposition
henry de lumley le voici en fouille avec
son épouse antoinette célèbre
anthropologue a été le concepteur
scientifique 12 ans d'élaboration du
nouveau musée de préhistoire des gorges
du verdon à quinson c'est même là son
sixième musée du genre un établissement
bourré d'innovations et de vestiges qui
font rêver comme les premiers outils
balbutiements du savoir faire et de la
survie il y a plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'années
quant au bâtiment le concours en a été
gagné par l'architecte britannique
foster son modernisme tout en courbes
édictées par l'accélération des
découvertes 60 millions de francs pour
cette création départementale calissons
de 6000 m² posé en plein provence au
milieu d'un patrimoine qui croît et
embellit même si dans ce passé plein
d'obscurité les questions sont encore
plus nombreuses que les réponses
le musée des gorges du verdon permettra
chaque jour un peu mieux de lire la
préhistoire à livre ouvert du football
elle la défaite des tricolores en corée
du sud les tricolores qui se sont
inclinés face à l'australie 1-0 pour le
deuxième match dans le groupe à de la
coupe des confédérations roland garros
avec l'élimination c'est d'après midi
juste de la française nathalie dechy qui
s'est incliné devant la slovaque 7 5 4 6
6 3 en 16e de finale difficile journée
aussi pour l'autre française virgine
razzano qui a été battu en deux manches
par la jeune belge justine henin 6 3 6 4
compte rendu que c'est bertrand
andy roddick rechute
la cuisse du jeune américain déjà blessé
n'a pas tenu le choc
dommage le duel avec lleyton hewitt
s'annonçait palpitant roddick champion
du monde junior nouvelle star du tennis
masculin contre hewitt le bouillonnant
australien mais le bras de fer s'arrête
à un set partout
l'intervention du médecin n'y fait rien
tarik benhabilès son entraîneur français
lui demande d'arrêter contraint et forcé
roddick renonce mais vu son talent ce
n'est que partie remise
les françaises aussi feront peut-être
mieux la prochaine fois
virginie razzano est prometteuse mais
face à justine henin l'expérience a
manqué la jeune française s'incline en
deux sets le jour de ses 19 ans justine
henin s'offre une place en huitièmes de
finale
nathalie dechy ya cru aussi un moment de
chine prend 1,7 à la slovaque nagy au
vam et la française fait beaucoup trop
de fautes et c'est dans trois manches
sandrine testud et maintenant le dernier
espoir français dans le tableau féminin
ac se termine ce journal je vous appelle
le principal titre après le suicide d'un
instituteur en avril dernier soupçonné
de pédophilie
des photos pornographiques ont été
découvertes dans son ordinateur mais
c'est nouveau ça continue malgré tout de
diviser les familles certaines convaincu
de l'innocence de l'enseignant dans un
instant la météo isabelle martinez puis
le coin route valérie maurice 20h50 et
mister burma avec guy marchand
23h55 le dernier journal jean claude de
renault quant à moi j'aurais plaisir de
vous retrouver demain dès 13 heures je
vous remercie de votre attention
excellente soirée sur france 2